Hong Kong's pro-democracy legislators
have failed in their court bid to
suspend a new ban on face masts at
demonstrations the new rule was put in
place by leader Carrie Lam let's get
more from Sarah Clark who joins us live
now from Hong Kong Sarah so just talk us
through what happened in court today
well this was a second attempt by a
group of pro-democracy lawmakers it was
filed in the High Court yesterday
Saturday and on Sunday it's just been
rejected and this was their attempt to
temporarily suspend this anti Moskva
which is an emergency law that was
enacted by Carrie Lam Hong Kong's chief
executive on Friday and their grounds
for their particular case was that they
believed it was unconstitutional and
infringed on Hong Kong's mini
Constitution which is the basic law and
that particular case has been rejected
but there is still an attempt by these
pro-democracy lawmakers to have a
judicial review to have this particular
anti-mask law are dumped altogether and
this is on Sunday as we are now
currently at the start of a number of
rallies who are mud people marching with
masks in to find divine the police ban a
bit showing their opposition to the
masks arrangement to basically
government ruling out that you can't
wear a mask in groups of more than 50
people all right there Sarah Clark there
in Hong Kong Sarah thank you